hey guys welcome back to brand-new
beauty Rebecca on foreign again today is
Thursday it is deaf to recap day and you
guys for coming along to the video I
just want to say real quick if the audio
sounds like [ __ ] I do apologize the
quality might not be the greatest and
that is most likely because I'm in my
car doing this I don't really have a
choice it's the way my schedules been
working for this semester of college I
either have to do it in there or in the
middle of a lunchroom and I'd rather
have peace and quiet in my car than a
[ __ ] ton of people screaming and yelling
at a lunchroom so I do apologize for
that hopefully it's not too bad but I'll
try to get that fixed for next week if
it is but going on with today's news we
do have a breach slayer challenge for
this weekend it's gonna be really cool
if you do want to play some breach and
get that challenge for the faction yeah
I believe it's either steel or xp ticket
so definitely want to get that so
definitely if it's the steel so you
could save up for those executions
coming next week which we'll get into a
little bit later as well there's going
to be a new arcade quest called Sol Mesa
if you have the marching fire DLC and
you do have arcade you can go play that
they didn't really specify what is in
there just another arcade class probably
some decent fights as well the content
of the week today is gonna be called a
new effect called Arctic collapse pretty
nice I ended up staying up to like seven
in the morning thinking it was gonna be
executions today but I was sadly wrong
but I would personally personally if you
do have this deal you can buy this
effect but to me I'm probably not going
to buy this one because I'm not a big
fan of the way it looks and I want to
save my steel for next week for the
executions also coming next week we're
gonna be seeing gameplay armor and
weapons for the Vorta grand for people
who are asking do not worry he will have
gear with full helmets on so you don't
have to look at his face you can cover
it up if that's the thing that you want
personally I like the way he looks so
I'm probably gonna keep in on masks but
everyone's a little bit different I
completely understand on top of that
executions will also be next week and
those were confirmed a little teaser for
4° executions as said by the devs is
that one of them is going to be very
brutal and deadly with his shield since
he likes to use his shield a lot in the
execution so it's very exciting to hear
but yeah that was really about it for
the video like I said not an incredibly
long stream it was about 20 to 30
minutes of the stream and that was about
it yeah but next week will be definitely
filled with loads of info that we'll be
getting out to you as soon as possible
as quick as I can like always guys next
week like I said we're gonna get
gameplay armor weapons executions all
that stuff for for dagger and of course
the full cast in terms of executions
that's very good stuff to know the
question of the video today is going to
be what type of execution would you want
for
knowing he's a sword and board hero do
you want him to slam his shield on top
of the opponent or the opponent tries to
get it in that one last hit and then for
dagger with his brick wall of a shield
knocks him down on the ground and
stabbed him in the chest and then
continues on with his day what would you
guys like to see in do and don't worry
if you don't think it's realistic we
threw the word realism out of 4 on her
back in season 1 when we added effects
and stuff like that so do not worry
about that at all that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
was gone a long time ago big guys like
the V if you do enjoy subscriber for new
I covered the informational site a
foreigner that being balanced changes
here are updates patch notes leaks all
that good stuff my two most recent
videos would be on-screen if you guys do
want to check that out with the guys so
ever great sure they think for watching
the video enjoy the rest of your day and
peace out
[Music]